خطوه اخرى على درب التطبيع بين السودان
واسرائيل في زياره لم تعلن حل وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي ايليكوهين بالخرطوم
حيث بحث مع عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني سبل ارساء علاقات مثمره
مع اسرائيل وتعزيز افاق التعاون المشترك
بين الخرطوم والتل ابيب وفق ما ذكر اعلام
مجلس السياده السوداني المؤيدون للتقارب
مع اسرائيل اعتبر ان السودان سيجني مكاسب
سياسيه واقتصاديه من وراء هذه الخطوه
السودان اذا تم بشكل جيد وشكل موثوق يحقق
السودان مصالح اقتصاديه يمكن من خلال ان
نرفع المعاناه للشعب السوداني خلال ان
يحقق اكبر قدرا من المساعدات الاقتصاديه
للسودانيين لنرفع عن السودانيين كاهل كاهل
السودانيين المعيشه الاقتصاديه الصعبه
التي يعاني منها ليست تقارب بين السودان
واسرائيل مفاجئا تماما فقد سبق لعبد
الفتاح البرهان ان اجرى محادثات رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهوغنديه قبل ثلاث سنوات
الا ان هذا الانفتاح على اسرائيل كان ما
تردد للوسط الكيانات السياسيه والحزبيه
ابانا فتره رئيس الوزراء السابق عبد الله
حمدوق ما بين مؤيد لتطبيع ومعارض له
بالنظر الى الطبيعه الاستراتيجيه والحساس
لهذه الملف الذي يتطلب موافقه برلمانيه
غائبه عن المشهد الانتقالي بالتاكيد واي
حكومه حتى لو كانت منتخبة تتخذ مثل هذا
الخطوه يجب ان ترجع الى البرلمان حتى
البرلمان يستصحب قيم السودانيين باعتباره
الشارع مصغر داخل جهاز الدوله وبالتالي
الخطوه كانت معزوله
مفصوله تماما عن اسيااق الثوره السودانيه
وسياق شعبه وسياق اقواها المدنيه
التيار الاسلامي العريض وحزب المؤتمر
الشعبي والحمله الشعبيه لمقاومه تطبيع
واعلاميون من اجل القدس جهات اجمعت على
رفض اي اتجاه لتطبيع السودان مع اسرائيل
واعتبروه خطوه مذله مؤكدين ان السلطه
الانتقاليه الحاليه لا تملك شرعيه تخولها
توقيع هذه الاتفاقيات وحضرت السلطه من
مغبه المضي فيما وصفوه ببيع اراده الشعب
في صفقات وصفوها بالخاسره
بينما يدفع مسؤولون سودانيون باتجاه
التطبيع مع اسرائيل تنظر قوى سياسيه
ومدنيه عديده الى هذه الخطوه على انها
مسار يقود الى طريق مسدود بل انها ترى فيه
توجهها يناقض ثوابت البلاد المناصره
للقضيه الفلسطينيه
اسامه سيد احمد الجزيره الخرطوم